[Música]
bienvenidos a este especial de noticias
hoy revelan con gusto como siempre
saludarnos en esta oportunidad donde
hablaremos y vamos también a analizar el
segundo discurso del estado de la nación
que hace el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador que realizará en el
patio de honor del palacio nacional el
mismo gobernante confirmó la asistencia
de 70 invitados entre los cuales estaban
representantes del sector obrero
indígenas empresarios son miembros de su
gabinete y también presidentes de la
cámara alta y baja del país los temas de
los que hablar a amlo y que él mismo
adelantó desde el día de ayer se
centrarán en la situación sanitaria y
económica a raíz de la pandemia de
coronavirus que ha dejado más de 64 mil
víctimas mortales en la gestión de la
que ha recibido fuertes críticas también
la corrupción será uno de los temas
principales además a su bandera de
política de estado también la estrategia
de seguridad de lucha contra el
narcotráfico hablará también sobre el
'team en el tratado con eeuu y canadá y
sobre las obras insignias de su gobierno
como la refinería dos bocas y el
aeropuerto feliz
y ángeles vamos a ver ahora el informe
que ha preparado nuestro periodista
andrés meza que nos cuenta cómo está la
nación hasta el día de hoy en medio de
toda esta pandemia de corona de luz
veamos
en la ciudad de monterrey un hombre
regala tatuajes a quienes hayan vencido
al cob y 19 sobrevivientes se escribe
sobre sus pieles y es que aunque en
méxico más de 400 mil personas han
vencido al virus casi 65 mil han muerto
a causa de la enfermedad el país tiene
hoy la mayor tasa de letalidad en todo
el mundo según el registro de la
universidad johns hopkins
casi 11 fallecidos por cada 100 personas
contagiadas muy por encima de eeuu y
brasil que juntos suman casi 10 millones
de casos positivos el kobe 19 llegó por
primera vez a méxico el 28 de febrero y
hoy 6 meses después es el octavo país
más afectado del mundo y el cuarto en
américa latina' al inicio del brote su
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
dejó claro su escepticismo frente al
impacto del virus ignorando el
distanciamiento social y alentando a las
aglomeraciones
y no dejen
y salir todavía estamos en la primera
fase ya nosotros yo les voy a decir
cuando no salga su actitud de reflejo en
la falta de pruebas hoy méxico es
señalado como el país de la organización
para la cooperación y el desarrollo
económico que menos pruebas realiza a su
población el mismo gobierno llegó a
reconocer que el recuento oficial no
reflejaba la cifra real de contagios
habló también se negaba a la aplicación
de medidas drásticas como el cierre de
aeropuertos y negocios no esenciales
pero los casos empezaron a dispararse
casi a finales de abril por lo que no
tuvo más remedio que seguir los pasos de
sus países vecinos pero estas medidas no
duraron mucho tiempo el primero de junio
ya habían salido de una cuarentena que
sólo duró dos meses tras la cual cada
región implementa medidas de acuerdo a
un semáforo epidemiológico es decir mide
las cantidades de casos en la zona para
decidir que puede estar abierto lópez
obrador reconoció que la emergencia
generada por la enfermedad ha provocado
la crisis económica más profunda
en un siglo
para analizar lo que va a ser este
discurso del presidente mexicano lópez
obrador vamos a tener a tres invitados a
todos desde la capital mexicana a ciudad
de mexico
vamos a tener a nuestro corresponsable
mario carbonell también al señor
raymundo rivapalacio periodista y
analista de política y el señor federico
arreola garcía el director de s
dp noticias gracias a todos por su
tiempo por estar aquí acompañándonos en
france24 pero quiero empezar entonces
con nuestro corresponsal en la capital
mexicana a mario o carbonell mario como
llega el presidente de obrador a este su
segundo discurso del estado además de
cara a estas elecciones intermedias del
año 2021 que podemos esperar de este
discurso mario también para entrar un
poco en contexto de nuestra audiencia
internacional le pregunto qué tan
importante son estas elecciones que
algunos también catalogan como
históricas
gracias buen día pues para empezar el
presidente llega con alguna baja alguna
disminución en su popularidad de acuerdo
con las más recientes encuestas
publicadas y en medio pues de un manejo
de la pandemia de comí 19 cuestionado
por las cifras altas de contagios y de
muertes comparados aunque él ha dicho
que pues no le gusta comparar pero lo
cierto es que con otros países con
población similar la cifra de muertos
por comida en mexico es muy alta también
la de contagios estamos rozando los 600
mil contagios y por esto que se
mencionaba ya en la pieza previamente
publicada de la escasez o de la falta de
pruebas suficientes una estrategia y un
vocero hugo lópez gatell que ha sido
pues cuestionado en la opinión pública
precisamente por estos incluso por
pronósticos fallidos se decía que pues
íbamos a llegar a los 60 miles de
muertos en el peor escenario y uno
catastrófico hacia el mes de octubre y
pues esa cifra ya se rebasó
en términos económicos pues también los
pronósticos no son alentadores en los
propios cálculos del banco de méxico por
no hablar de las agencias y las
calificadoras que pues se prevén un una
contracción del producto interno bruto
significativa de dos dígitos incluso y
el presidente pues ha dicho que ya
tocamos fondo que vamos en el camino de
la recuperación aunque esto pues está
por verse recientemente el secretario de
hacienda arturo herrera ha dicho que
méxico está en la peor crisis desde 1932
y lo cierto es que el panorama pues es
incierto en cuanto a la recuperación
económica a pesar de que el presidente
pues presume que hay estabilidad
financiera que hay una macroeconomía
sana y que la el ritmo de generación de
empleo se está recuperando a pesar de la
caída fuerte que tuvo retomando tu
segunda pregunta en cuanto a las
elecciones pues son las elecciones muy
importantes
y ahí se verá realmente la fuerza que
tiene el partido en el gobierno porque
como es conocido pues en 2018
el efecto de lópez obrador pues arrasó
en las urnas con la votación las más
altas en la historia reciente se sin
embargo pues el ejercicio de gobierno ha
provocado un desgaste y también el
partido está debilitado por eso será
pues una buena medición en cuanto al
ejercicio de este gobierno mariotto
interrumpa y entonces es directo al
patio de honor del palacio nacional de
méxico donde a esta hora entonces se
pronuncia el presidente de lópez obrador
escuchamos realizar
es el gobierno
no será recordado por corrupto
[Música]
nuestro principal legado sera
purificar la vida pública de méxico
y estamos avanzando
no hemos emprendido persecuciones
facciosas ni venganzas políticas
pero tampoco encubrimos a nadie
ni permitimos la impunidad
ya se acabó la robadera de los de arriba
pero todavía falta desterrar por
completo el bandidaje oficial
la austeridad republicana
es una realidad
son hechos no palabras
ya no hay lujos en el gobierno
y todo lo que se ahorra se destina a
conseguir el bienestar del pueblo
según cálculos oficiales
por no permitir la corrupción
y por hacer un gobierno austero
hemos podido ahorrar durante nuestra
administración alrededor de 560 mil
millones de pesos
no es para presumir pero en el peor
momento contamos con el mejor gobierno
estamos enfrentando dos crisis al mismo
tiempo la sanitaria y la económica y
vamos saliendo adelante
la pandemia no es un asunto político
sino de salud pública por eso
he confiado las decisiones en esta
materia un equipo de profesionales con
gran experiencia y capacidades
el coronavirus nos ha dejado dolor
tristeza y penurias pero también ha
fortalecido el amor en las familias
ha demostrado el humanismo y la entrega
de los trabajadores de la salud
[Música]
ha resaltado la conocida fraternidad de
nuestro pueblo
es indudable que saldremos de la
pandemia con un mejor sistema de salud
recibimos el gobierno con 401 hospitales
abandonados saqueados oa medio construir
y con un déficit de más de 200.000
profesionales de la medicina
en pocos meses hemos reconvertido con el
apoyo de los gobiernos estatales de la
secretaría de marina y de la secretaría
de la defensa 969 hospitales para
atender pacientes con kobe 19 se han
instalado 32 mil 203 camas y 10.000
612 con ventiladores
así mismo se han contratado 47 mil
médicos generales
especialistas enfermeras y otros
trabajadores de la salud
propusimos ante la 1 y se aprobó casi
por unanimidad
una iniciativa para que los medicamentos
y las vacunas tengan carácter no
lucrativo
méxico participa en los principales de
esfuerzos internacionales para
desarrollar una vacuna contra el kobe 19
de manera específica destacó el
compromiso que hicimos con la
universidad de oxford con el laboratorio
astrazéneca con la fundación carlos slim
y con el gobierno de argentina esperamos
que ese acuerdo de resultados desde
noviembre y que podamos empezar a
aplicar la vacuna a más tardar a
principios del año próximo de manera
universal y gratuita
[Música]
la emergencia sanitaria mundial vivida
este año
ha planteado problemas muy graves para
todos los países y nos obligará a todos
a repensar y a cambiar muchas cosas
además del tremendo dolor que ha causado
la pandemia ha quedado comprobado que
sus efectos son más graves si padecemos
de hipertensión de obesidad de diabetes
por eso debemos cuidar nuestra
alimentación y no consumir productos
chatarra con excesos de azúcares sales y
químicos por no
y químicos por nuestra salud debemos
practicar el ejercicio y el deporte para
fortalecer nuestro sistema inmune y
bajar de peso
estamos enfrentando la crisis económica
provocada por la pandemia con una
fórmula distinta peculiar heterodoxa
diría
única en el mundo
ahora todos los apoyos y créditos se
entregan de manera directa para
reactivar la economía de abajo hacia
arriba
no se da prioridad a las grandes
empresas y bancos ahora por el bien de
todos primero se rescata al pueblo
es motivo de orgullo poder decir que en
siete de cada diez familias está
llegando cuando menos un beneficio o
algo del presupuesto público que es
dinero de todos
además para tranquilidad de nuestra
conciencia y felicidad
de todas y todos
el 100 por ciento de las comunidades
indígenas y de los más pobres del campo
y de la ciudad se benefician con al
menos uno de los programas sociales aquí
recuerdo todo lo que sostenía adam smith
que bien podría constituir uno de los
fundamentos de la economía moral que
estamos aplicando decía
por más egoísta que quiera suponerse al
hombre y evidentemente hay algunos
elementos en su naturaleza que lo hacen
interesarse en la suerte de los otros de
tal modo que la felicidad de éstos le es
necesaria aunque de ello nada obtenga a
no ser el placer
y agregaría el inmenso placer de
presenciar la en otras palabras la
alegría ajena es nuestra propia dicha
no obstante nos han reprochado que no
emprendimos un rescate económico
elitista para atenuar los efectos de la
pandemia
pero es un timbre de orgullo poder decir
que ayudamos por medio de los programas
sociales a 23 millones de familias
imagínense cuántos adultos mayores han
podido observar la reclusión sanitaria
por contar con el derecho a recibir una
pensión casi sea modesta
ya se reformó el artículo cuarto
constitucional para convertir los apoyos
destinados a los adultos mayores ya
niñas y niños con discapacidad así como
el otorgamiento de becas a estudiantes
de familias pobres y la atención médica
y los medicamentos gratuitos en derechos
sociales prioritarios
pues ahí lo tenían ustedes entonces en
pantalla al presidente mexicano andrés
lópez obrador entregando una cuenta y
pues en lo que ha sido entonces su
gestión de gobierno durante el período
2019 y el 2020 empezó hablando sobre su
lucha contra la corrupción la lucha que
ha hecho su gobierno contra la
corrupción del país dijo que se acabó la
robadera también habló sobre los logros
de su gobierno en cuanto a esta pandemia
que sufre méxico y pues por supuesto
también todo el mundo de el hobbit
19 dijo que todos los recursos que se ha
ahorrado el gobierno en austeridad del
gobierno que proclamó el presidente
obrador desde que tomó posesión es dijo
que todos esos recursos y todos esos
ahorros se ven reflejados directamente
en ayuda para el pueblo también dijo que
la pandemia de coronavirus es un asunto
de salud pública y habló también de qué
el sistema de salud mexicano se ha
fortalecido tras lo que ha sido toda
esta pandemia de coronavirus también
habló por supuesto de la vacuna que se
estaba desarrollando conjuntamente con
argentina y el laboratorio astrazéneca
habló que en principio se espera que
esta vacuna ya esté lista para aplicarse
a las personas a principios del año que
viene hablo que va a ser una vacuna
universal es decir para todo el mundo y
también de manera gratuita también hablo
un tema muy particular y polémica
también que ha sido en mexico sobre la
comida chatarra sobre la obesidad sobre
las bebidas azucaradas dijo que hay que
evitar la obesidad y tratar de comer
menos de comida chatarra menos azúcares
para evitar ser obesos porque es una de
las comorbilidades que afectan que te
agrava la enfermedad de kobe 19 a las
personas que dan a positivo para para
esta enfermedad y dijo que también con
su rescate económico de gobierno
entonces ha ayudado a
23 millones de familias mexicanas quiero
empezar entonces a analizar un poco de
lo que de lo que hemos visto y lo que
escuchamos anteriormente sobre esta
memoria y cuenta del presidente mexicano
con el mundo rivapalacio él es
periodista y analista y conductor
especializado en análisis de política y
la economía mexicana señor rivapalacio
gracias nuevamente por estar con
nosotros aquí en nuestro especial de
noticias y gracias por su tiempo se
acabó la robadera entonces en mexico
como lo ha dicho el presidente el
presidente de obrador que hemos visto
hasta ahora lo poco que podemos escuchar
del discurso del presidente bueno hasta
este momento no ha habido absolutamente
nada nada original nada nuevo incluso
hay una serie de fases que repite
constantemente algunas de estas frases
esto es la robadera y el bandidaje con
el cual arrancó suba su mensaje lo dijo
inclusive ayer pero nos tiene
acostumbrados a esto
este es el segundo informe gobierno en
realidad él da informes cada tres meses
este sería el décimo segundo reporte que
da sobre sobre el estado de cosas pero
es prácticamente lo mismo que ha
repetido en cada uno de estos de estos
informes por lo tanto no hay que no hay
novedades no hay ninguna sorpresa
todavía en el informe no vamos a esperar
ninguna sorpresa eres muy predecible en
ese sentido si hay cosas que hay que
resaltar porque me llaman la atención
una que me acaba de sorprender porque
eso sí no recordaba yo haberlo oído es
que cita a adam smith él presume ser un
gobernante de izquierda aunque su
política económica es profundamente
conservadora el que critica el crítica
mucho en lo que él llama lo que
conocemos popularmente como el modelo
del sistema económico neoliberal pero él
es probablemente el presidente más
conservador y más neoliberal en esos
términos
que hemos tenido aquí en méxico por eso
es muy interesante que su referencia
económica sea adam smith best-seller de
liberalismo económico de la economía
clásica y cuando él habla también de la
austeridad republicana en realidad lo
que está sucediendo es un achicamiento
profundo del gobierno el ideal de todos
los gobiernos liberales es llevar al
gobierno al mínimo al mínimo posible de
operación qué es lo que está haciendo y
hoy seguramente se anuncia ya
oficialmente la desaparición de diez de
sus secretarías de estado algunas de
ellas muy importantes pero desaparecen
todo esto lo que es el gasto operativo
y hay otra cosa que que él no está y él
no lo dice pero está en el interlineado
de su mensaje sé que lo que ha hecho en
términos económicos que dice que lo han
hecho muy bien y ni siquiera estoy
llegando al momento de la pandemia
haberse haberse chupado por la mano de
alguna manera se las 500 mil millones de
pesos 300 mil millones de pesos ya le
había dejado pero enrique peña nieto
está recuperando la imagen bebé
y lo que ha hecho es básicamente tirar
esos 500 mil millones de pesos a la
basura sí señor rivapalacio entonces
vamos vamos a hacer algo escuchemos
continuamos escuchando al presidente
borrador y ya seguimos andando en el
tema y también con nuestro invitado
vamos a méxico con el presidente grados
en el mes de agosto
se crearon 93.000 nuevos empleos
el peso se apreció al cotizarse a menos
de 22 pesos por dólar luego de haber
estado a más de 25
la mezcla mexicana del petróleo de 0
paso a 40 dólares por barril
el consumo de productos básicos en vez
de reducirse con la pandemia aumentó en
9.5 por ciento en términos reales con
relación al año pasado la recaudación de
impuestos se mantuvo prácticamente igual
en 2019 lo mismo sucedió con la
inversión extranjera directa durante el
primer semestre del año llegó a 17 mil
969 millones de dólares
lo mismo que en 2019 la caída de la
economía a pesar del desastre mundial
fue de 10.4 por ciento en el semestre
pero aún con la debacle fue menor el
daño que nos causó
la crisis económica que nos está
afectando que
lo que
se está registrando en otros países como
italia españa francia y reino unido-
debo agregar que casi todos los países
recurrieron a créditos y aumentaron sus
deudas en porcentajes elevadísimos
en contraste nosotros hemos enfrentado a
la pandemia y vamos a salir
de la crisis económica sin contratar
deuda
adicional y sin destinar dinero público
a rescates entre comillas inmorales es
decir a quienes no necesitan ser
rescatados
pero no debe olvidarse que al enfocar la
solidaridad gubernamental a los más
pobres también beneficiamos
indirectamente a los sectores que tienen
alguna o mucha capacidad de ahorro los
programas sociales han permitido a
millones de beneficiarios preservar algo
de su poder adquisitivo y de su
capacidad de consumo y por eso no se ha
cerrado el mercado a miles de empresas y
de comercios la relación con los
empresarios ha sido buena y respetuosa a
pesar de la crisis la mayoría no
despidió
a sus empleados
baste un dato
antes de la pandemia
estaban inscritos en el seguro social
20 millones
500 mil
trabajadores
cerca de un millón de empresas
los momentos más difíciles se perdieron
un millón de empleos
y ya estamos recuperándonos
cuántos empleos
y se mantuvieron a pesar de la pandemia
18 19 millones 500 mil empleos
la mayoría de las empresas mantuvo a sus
trabajadores
los empresarios mexicanos cumplen con
sus contribuciones
aceptaron aceptaron aumentar
el año pasado
16 por ciento al salario mínimo este año
20% al salario mínimo y decidieron
voluntariamente aportar más para
pensionar mejor a los trabajadores
además los hospitales privados nos han
ayudado a enfrentar la pandemia y las
televisoras de empresas particulares nos
están apoyando para transmitir clases
por radio y televisión a 30 millones de
estudiantes no tengo más que decirles
gracias en nombre del gobierno y de
nuestro pueblo
méxico es un país sin duda con porvenir
y un ejemplo mundial de cómo hacer
realidad el progreso con justicia la
principal riqueza de una nación no está
en su infraestructura
[Música]
o en sus finanzas y ni siquiera en sus
recursos naturales sino en su población
y sus culturas
en la gente que la conforman y le da
historia y existencia
e invertir en ella
en la población
en los mexicanos
en el pueblo
invertir en su alimentación su salud su
educación y su bienestar en general es
lo mejor que se puede hacer para
garantizar la fortaleza del país y su
desarrollo presente y futuro
desde julio pasado entró en vigor el
nuevo tratado comercial con canadá y
eeuu en estos momentos de crisis el
acuerdo que firmamos significa impulsar
las actividades productivas conseguir
más inversión extranjera crear más
empleos y lograr más bienestar para
nuestro pueblo
en este contexto debe verse mi visita a
washington para entrevistarme con el
presidente de donald trump quien nos
trató con respeto y lo más importante
elogió a nuestros paisanos que viven y
trabajan honradamente en eeuu de américa
mantenemos buenas relaciones con todos
los pueblos y gobiernos del mundo
en materia de política exterior nos
apegamos a los principios
constitucionales de no intervención
autodeterminación de los pueblos
solución pacífica de las controversias y
cooperación para el desarrollo como es
sabido méxico fue el país que más votos
obtuvo para formar parte del consejo de
seguridad de la onu
con el apoyo de los trabajadores y de
los técnicos de pemex y de la comisión
federal de electricidad estamos
rescatando a estas empresas públicas
haciéndolas más eficientes limpiando las
de corrupción y cumpliendo el compromiso
de no aumentar el precio de las
gasolinas del diesel del gas de la luz
y esto lo vamos
sostener durante todo el sexenio
por convicción hemos decidido cuidar el
medio ambiente como nunca lo hicieron
los anteriores gobiernos y lo más
interesante ni lo demandaron los pseudo
ecologistas que tanto nos atacan solo
subrayó que estamos aplicando el
programa de reforestación más importante
del mundo sembrando
1100 millones de árboles frutales y
maderables
no se permite el uso del maíz
transgénico ni el fracking se cuida el
agua y uno hemos entregado ni una sola
concesión para la explotación minera
no se puede olvidar que en el período
neoliberal
sólo en 30 años de 1988 hasta noviembre
de 2018
las cinco administraciones pasadas
otorgaron concesiones por 118 millones
de hectáreas para la explotación minera
el equivalente al 60 por ciento del
territorio nacional ese entreguismo
devastador ya se acabó
al de cerrar la corrupción
el conacyt pudo orientarse a fortalecer
el bienestar del pueblo por medio del
desarrollo científico así asignado becas
con transparencia y equidad a 84 mil 599
estudiantes ya 34 mil 447 académicos con
una inversión anual por 19 mil 132
millones de pesos 14 por ciento más que
en 2018
desde finales de este año
nos haremos cargo de que los médicos que
quieran especializarse no sean
rechazados como ha venido sucediendo y
puedan formarse tanto en el país como en
el extranjero estamos contemplando
garantizar espacios educativos y
entregar durante nuestro gobierno 70 mil
becas a estos profesionales de la
medicina que ayudarán a reducir el
déficit de especialistas que tienen
nuestro país y que nos impide garantizar
por completo el derecho del pueblo a la
salud asimismo se han sentado las bases
de la independencia tecnológica logrando
en poco tiempo entre otras aportaciones
el desarrollo y fabricación de los
primeros ventiladores 100% mexicanos
para salvar vidas
por covite 19
descargado de manera gratuita 683.000
libros digitales del fondo de cultura
económica tenemos 45 librerías
reactivadas de la red fondo de cultura
económica educar con venta en mostrador
y absolutas condiciones sanitarias
ha crecido han crecido las alas y los
clubes de lectura en comunidades y en
escuelas normales seguimos produciendo
traducciones y nuevos libros
la colección 'vientos del pueblo'
llegará esta semana a 43 títulos con
libros de 8
de pesos
40 mil ejemplares
tal
como nos habíamos comprometidos y
comidas a la conmemoración
el año próximo de los 700 años de la
fundación de tenochtitlan de los 500
años de la invasión colonial
y de los 200 años de la consumación de
nuestra independencia
han comenzado a entrar en imprenta los
títulos de la colección 21 para el 21
para ser entregados masivamente a partir
del año que viene en ediciones de 100
mil ejemplares producidos por el fondo
de cultura económica y financiados por
el instituto para devolver al pueblo lo
robado que incluyen obras de guillermo
elena pone a tosca octavio paz-
emilio abreu gómez mariano azuela
vicente rivapalacio martín luis guzmán
josé s valadez luis villoro emilio
carballido nellie campobello carlos
monsiváis y el liberto frías
quiero destacar que por primera vez una
mujer indígena será la titular del
consejo nacional
para prevenir la discriminación
[Música]
también informó que continúa el programa
de apoyo preferente a los pueblos
originarios con ese propósito
acabamos de suscribir un acuerdo de
justicia con los gobernadores de los
pueblos yaquis
además seguimos promoviendo el arte
y todas las expresiones culturales
continuamos restaurando templos y
monumentos históricos y están en proceso
de construcción el parque ecológico del
lago de texcoco y el espacio artístico y
cultural de los pinos en el bosque de
chapultepec
vamos viento en popa en la construcción
del aeropuerto felipe ángeles
también está avanzando se conforme a
programa en la construcción de la nueva
refinería de dos bocas paraíso tabasco
ya se iniciaron los trabajos para el
tren maya estamos haciendo realidad el
desarrollo del istmo de tehuantepec para
comunicar a los países de asia con la
costa este de los eeuu
además estas obras generarán 150 mil
empleos en el transcurso de este año
de este año
estamos avanzando en el combate a la
delincuencia
hemos establecido una nueva estrategia
que empieza por procurar trabajo
educación y bienestar a las personas que
están en riesgo de ser reclutadas por
los grupos delictivos especialmente
jóvenes la lucha contra la pobreza el
desempleo y la marginación va acompañada
del despliegue de la guardia nacional un
cuerpo de paz y de proximidad con la
población con presencia en todas las
regiones del país que cuenta ya con 97
mil elementos bien equipados y formados
para alojar a estos responsables de la
seguridad del pueblo se han construido
79 cuarteles se encuentran en proceso 34
y están por iniciarse 135 más con lo
cual llegaremos a doscientos cuarenta y
ocho cuarteles a finales del 2021
casi en todos los delitos ha habido
disminución en comparación con noviembre
de 2018 hay menos secuestros
feminicidios robos a transeúntes a
transportistas
menos robo de vehículos
robo en transporte público
colectivo menos robo en transporte
público individual menos robo a negocios
y menos robo a casas-habitación
en todos ellos
será registrado una baja del orden del
30 por ciento en promedio sólo han
aumentado dos delitos homicidio doloso y
extorsión en 7.9 y 12.7 por ciento
respectivamente vinculados estos delitos
fundamentalmente a la llamada
delincuencia organizada
en esta tarea
ha sido fundamental el apoyo profesional
y responsable de las fuerzas armadas
en particular agradezco el respaldo
la lealtad y el recto proceder del
almirante rafael ojeda durán y del
general
luís crescencio sandoval gonzález
secretarios de marina y de la defensa
nacional servidores públicos ejemplares
ahora hay justicia para el pobre y en
materia de seguridad ya no manda la
delincuencia organizada como era antes
ya no hay torturas
desapariciones ni masacres se respetan
los derechos humanos y se castiga al
culpable sea quien sea ya no hay en el
gobierno federal funcionarios como
garcía luna
es mantenido
y seguiré manteniendo una relación
institucional con las autoridades
emanadas de otros partidos
la unsj y los gobernadores y presidentes
municipales de cualquier signo político
encuentran en el ejecutivo federal
respeto y trato equitativo
hemos cumplido nuestra promesa de
impulsar la verdadera independencia de
las instituciones de justicia
la fiscalía general de la república y el
poder judicial de la federación actúan
con absoluta autonomía y se acabó
aquello de que todo lo ordenaba el
presidente porque el ejecutivo era el
poder de los poderes
miren
como han cambiado las cosas invité al
fiscal general de la república del
presidente de la suprema corte de
justicia y no pudieron asistir
en otros tiempos eso no pasa
porque ellos tienen
la arrogancia de sentirse libres
este es el cambio esta es la
transformación
en los casos
en los que están
están implicados ex presidentes de la
república
he propuesto que las autoridades
responsables de salud en el asunto con
absoluta libertad y que de ser necesario
se celebre una consulta para conocer la
opinión del pueblo he dicho y reitero
que yo votaría
por no someterlos a proceso pues
mantengo la postura que sostuve desde mi
toma de posesión según la cual en el
terreno de la justicia se puede castigar
los errores del pasado pero lo
fundamental es evitar los delitos del
porvenir
sin embargo de realizarse la consulta
respetar el fallo popular sea cual sea
porque la democracia el pueblo decide y
por convicción me he propuesto mandar
obedeciendo
como muchos mexicanos fui víctima del
fraude electoral y estoy convencido del
tremendo daño que ocasionan las
autoridades impuestas
por eso se reformó la constitución y se
castigará con cárcel y sin derecho a
fianza a quien utilice el presupuesto
público en beneficio de partidos y
candidatos o adultere el carácter libre
y democrático de las elecciones
desde francisco y madero nunca un
presidente había sido tan atacado como
ahora
los conservadores están enojados porque
ya no hay corrupción y perdieron
privilegios
sin embargo gozan de una absoluta
libertad de expresión y ello es prueba
de que hoy se garantizan las libertades
y el derecho a disentir la represión
política ha quedado en el pasado
estamos llevando a cabo la cuarta
transformación de la vida pública de
méxico y es pertinente recordar
que las tres primeras transformaciones
la independencia la reforma y la
revolución tuvieron que hacerse con las
armas ahora lo estamos logrando de
manera pacífica
hay oposición al gobierno
como debe de existir en toda auténtica
democracia
pero la mayoría de los habitantes de
méxico aprueban nuestra gestión
gracias les doy a todas ya todos
por la confianza no le fallaré al pueblo
de mexico
amigas y amigos hoy por la tarde como lo
establece la ley
[Música]
la licenciada olga sánchez cordero
secretaria de gobernacion entregará al
congreso de la unión el segundo informe
del gobierno que represento
es mucho lo realizado
miren
en lo fundamental nos queda realmente
poco por definir
de los 100 compromisos que hice en el
zócalo el primero de diciembre de 2018
hemos cumplido 95
y sólo están pendientes cinco
compromisos o en proceso de que se
cumplan
desde el primer día de mi gobierno se ha
venido aplicando el proyecto de nación
que propusimos a la sociedad y que
obtuvo un respaldo abrumador en las
urnas el primero de julio
y ustedes entonces lo veían en pantalla
era el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador haciendo una memoria y cuenta un
recuento entonces de lo que ha sido su
último año de gobierno desde el año 2019
hasta el 2020 creo entonces que ya
tenemos al presidente operadores de
nuevo con nosotros escuchemos lo que son
parte de sus declaraciones para luego
hacer el correspondiente análisis con
nuestros invitados y por supuesto con
nuestro corresponsal en la capital
mexicana
las acciones gubernamentales realizadas
son expresión de lo que hemos soñado
diseñado y ofrecido desde hace muchos
años
corresponden a una visión de país y una
visión de lo que debe de ser
un mundo justo y fraterno
hoy algunos críticos piden que se
gobierne en sentido distinto
que prescindamos de nuestro diario y de
nuestro proyecto
que apliquemos recetas económicas contra
las que hemos luchado
o que seamos tolerantes con la
corrupción que nos propusimos erradicar
piden en suma que yo traicioné mi
compromiso con la sociedad que falte a
mi palabra
y que renuncie a mi congruencia y eso
lógicamente
no va a ocurrir
ya está en marcha la nueva política
económica sustentada en la moralidad la
austeridad y el desarrollo con justicia
sigue en pie el compromiso de terminar
de sentar las bases del méxico del
porvenir para el primero de diciembre
próximo cuando se cumplan dos años de
gobierno a partir de entonces una vez
que se tengan construidos los cimientos
sólo quedará la tarea de terminar la
obra de transformación y seguir
gobernando con rectitud y amor al pueblo
para contar siempre con su respaldo
estoy convencido que la mejor manera de
evitar retrocesos en el futuro depende
mucho de continuar con la revolución de
las conciencias para lograr la plenitud
un cambio de mentalidad
que cuando sea necesario se convierta en
voluntad colectiva dispuesta a defender
lo alcanzado en beneficio del interés
público y de la nación
sigamos pues haciendo historia sigamos
pues haciendo patria por nosotros y por
las nuevas generaciones que sabrán
honrar la dignidad de nuestro pueblo y
la grandeza de méxico que viva méxico
viva méxico viva méxico
[Aplausos]
era entonces el presidente mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador haciendo las
declaraciones sobre su segundo informe
de gobierno correspondiente al año 2019
y 2020 ya en esta segunda parte entonces
del discurso que estábamos viendo aquí
en las pantallas de france 24 habló de
la del aumento en la inversión
extranjera directa también habló de las
clases por radio y televisión que ha
dispuesto el gobierno mexicano para
educar a los niños que no pueden acceder
a las escuelas
ahora en la actualidad por cuenta de
esta pandemia de kobe 19 también habló
de un tema muy importante y fue el
tratado de libre comercio entre estados
unidos canadá y méxico el simec dijo que
con este tratado se buscaba impulsar
estas actividades económicas volvió a
hablar entonces de la inversión
extranjera también habló sobre la
polémica visita de
obrador a washington muy criticada por
algunos mexicanos diciendo que el
presidente obrador fue muy
condescendiente y complaciente con el
gobierno del presidente donald trump que
por supuesto hemos visto como el
gobierno de tram y precisamente de la
misma boca ante el presidente criticando
a los mexicanos y también sobre el
polémico muro fronterizo entre estados
unidos y méxico que el presidente de
donald trump volvió a decir en esta
carrera presidencial de cara a las
elecciones de noviembre que los
mexicanos van a para a pagar por ese
muro con más impuestos también habló del
compromiso ambiental del gobierno del
presidente obrador dijo que era un
programa de reforestación entre otros y
habló de que se respetaba la decisión de
no hacer fracking para explotar más
recursos petroleros también habló por
supuesto de un respeto y apoyo a los
pueblos
otra bandera de su campaña política
cuando se lanzaba a la presidencia y
habló también del combate a la
delincuencia la pobreza el desempleo y
también habló de una disminución de
todos los delitos en el territorio
mexicano en su gobierno esto es un poco
ha sido entonces el resumen de este
segundo informe de gobierno del
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador y estábamos hablando
precisamente antes de que comenzara este
en este discurso del presidente obrador
o con nuestros invitados o me quedé con
el señor raymundo rivapalacio y quiero
volver con ustedes señor rivapalacio
entonces para analizar un poco de lo que
fue finalmente este discurso del
presidente obrador y qué y si es cierto
que cumplió los 95 de los 100
compromisos desde que se posicionado
como presidente de mexico
sí creo que tenemos entonces un poco de
problemas con el señor raymundo palacio
desde la ciudad de mexico para entonces
ahora quiero saludar a nuestro raymundo
ya ya me está escuchando
adelante señor el señor palacio tiene
usted entonces la palabra de lo que
estaba preguntando un poco para analizar
lo que ha sido este discurso del
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador y lo que lo que nos habíamos
quedado antes de retomar con el
presidente mencionaba ellos que hasta
dónde iba no había dicho absolutamente
nada nuevo una vez que ya terminó
podemos comprobar que no dijo
absolutamente nada nuevo no hay no hubo
nada que no hubiera venido repitiendo ya
ayer antier todas las semanas todos los
meses
si yo diría que hay varias cosas en lo
cual el presidente utiliza mucho
sofismas hace mucho silogismos en
algunos algunos aspectos incluso él
asume como
cuestiones que no tienen nada que ver
dados un punto muy importante en esto es
el cuando habla de la precisión del peso
mexicano era del preso mexicano no se
debe a ninguna política económica tiene
que ver con el diferencial de las tasas
de interés que hay en méxico está en 4.5
por ciento frente estados en los que
estén cero por supuesto que hay mucho
aquí se obtienen utilidades que no se
obtienen en otros países pero bueno este
es solamente un ejemplo hay algunas
cosas que es muy tramposo cuando habla
por ejemplo de los ahorros por 500 por
50 y 560 mil millones de pesos en
realidad eso ese ahorro que dice no es
un ahorro el 90% viene de los impuestos
a las gasolinas el subsidio a las
gasolinas se aquí hay una fórmula en la
cual mensualmente o semanalmente que uso
se van
aplicando el subsidio se va se va
suspendiendo su sitio en función de cómo
están los precios del mercado él dice
que lo maneja con que su compromiso era
que no iba a haber habla de los
complejos que no era ver un incremento
en los impuestos a las gasolinas en
realidad sí y es un impuesto que ya
existía es un impuesto que tiene que ver
con esta fórmula no es nada malo que se
haga es una forma de recaudación para el
gobierno desde el gobierno de enrique
peña nieto lo que digo es que son de las
trampas que él mencionó a lo largo de
esta del discurso y hablan del combate a
la delincuencia menciona todos los
rubros en los cuales bajó el índice
delictivo lo cual es absolutamente
incorrecto es cierto por una razón
bajaron aquellos rubros en donde la
gente estaba confinada no sale a la
calle por lo tanto ese tipo de delitos
patrimoniales en casa robos de libros se
disminuyeron en términos de homicidio
doloso
el indicador más importante sobre el
tema del combate a la delincuencia de la
seguridad está en momento en que vivimos
en agosto el segundo mes más violento en
la historia de este país el primer mes
fue también durante este año hay más de
100 de 58 mil muertos probablemente al
terminar el año sea el año más
sangriento que méxico ha tenido en su
historia se ha subido de 81 muertos en
julio de vido muertos por día en julio a
100 muertos por día en agosto entonces
se menciona son esta parte de verdades
verdades a medias o algunas mentiras
habla también sobre el medio ambiente
este es el gobierno menos ecologista que
hemos tenido él presume el programa de
sembrando vida que es con lo que le
llaman de reforestación habla de esta
suma impresionante de árboles nada más
que baje en un 6 por ciento de su
aplicación
un total fracaso y contrario a esto se
enfrenta o está en contra de la de la
energía eólica
que también está a favor por ejemplo de
la recría de dos bocas y ahí hay una
política sobre energía sucia esa es la
que tiene el presidente lo acusado por
ello seguir y seguir hablando sobre los
sofismas y las mentiras que acabamos de
escuchar del presidente del acusado pero
insisto no es algo que nos sorprenda
todos los días produce de 7 a 10
mentiras o verdades no comprobables en
sus conferencias de prensa matutina sí
señoría palacio gracias entonces por su
opinión ahora quiero saludar a nuestro
otro invitado federico arreola garcía el
ex director de ese de noticias señor
arriola gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en france 24 como le
preguntaba al señor rivapalacio también
quisiera saber entonces su opinión sobre
lo que acabamos de escuchar el discurso
del estado del presidente de lópez
obrador sobre lo que fue un balance de
su gobierno de 2019 2020 su último año
de gobierno se tiene la palabra
gracias raúl buenos días buenos días a
mí me gustaría
comenzar con lo que dice raymundo que no
hay sorpresas pues no hay sorpresas no
pues no podríamos esperar una sorpresa
de un gobierno
y comunica como ningún otro o sea no
llevamos dos informes de gobierno no
llevamos ni siquiera doce porque hace un
gobierno cada tres un informe cada tres
meses
llevamos seiscientos porque hace uno
cada mañana entonces y todo todo lo que
había dicho hoy ya lo hemos escuchado yo
que intentó seguir todas las mañaneras
todo lo que dijo ya lo he escuchado en
algún momento y no me gustaría empezar a
hablar de lo malo
por qué
ya creo que todos hicieron hincapié en
las cosas que ven mal a mí me gustaría
en realidad hablar de las cosas
que sirvió con por logros
empezó hablando del tema de
corrupción y es un hecho o sea si es un
hecho que la corrupción
ha bajado al nivel más alto porque nadie
puede negar que él no sea un tipo
honesto en sí
y una cosa que a mí me parece
importantísima es lo que dijo de los
rescates inmorales los rescates a las
empresas a los empresarios a los de
arriba sí es cierto que cambio el modelo
tan es cierto que cambió el modelo que
este es el gobierno en el que las
grandes empresas que tenían unos grandes
créditos fiscales con nada con hacienda
han estado pagando esos previstos
créditos de que vienen de otros
gobiernos que nadie se atrevía a
cobrarles impuestos a estas empresas
hablo de empresas enormes como ofensa y
wal mart transnacionales mineras y creo
que eso es un loco cosas y si no hay si
no es un logro hacer que las grandes
empresas paguen lo que tienen que pagar
entonces que es un logro
y creo que eso
si lo juntas con la disminución con el
adelgazamiento del gobierno
se traduce en que por esta en esta gran
crisis mundial que hay los las hay
viudas los apoyos a los adultos mayores
a los estudiantes a las becas hayan
estado llegando incluso a los adultos
mayores se les adelantó por tres meses
sus ayudas para que no salieran y no se
pusieran en riesgo
y esas ayudas a los de abajo nunca se
pusieron en riesgo entonces creo que la
gente votó por estos hay ya sabíamos ya
sabía que la gente cómo iba a hacer un
gobierno de lópez obrador
lópez obrador no es críptico lópez
obrador nunca quiere dar un mensaje que
no un mensaje oculto en las cosas todo
lo que dice lo hace y así actuó cuando
fue jefe del gobierno de la ciudad de
mexico
entonces la gente votó por un gobierno
que ya sabíamos como con cómodo como
sería y en el peor momento no de méxico
nuestro momento mundial que yo recuerde
ha sido la crisis esta del cob y de
estas ayudas a la gente no nunca para
ron entonces creo que creo que eso es un
eso es un logro que no debemos dejar osa
y algo que dicen es lo dijo raymundo
ahora y no lo escuchado de raimundo a
quien aprecio muchísimo es lo escuchado
lo he leído en muchas columnas me ha
escuchado en radio de analistas de todo
que qué gran problema qué gran error no
no fue el habernos el habernos encerrado
en el que el gobierno haya sido más duro
porque no nos no nos llevó al
confinamiento como en otros países
porque no se lo exigía a nadie incluso
criticada lópez obrador a los estados
donde donde se encerró a la gente con un
poco de más autoridad de más de mano
dura y ahora dice raymundo no es que por
el confinamiento es por lo que bajaron
los los delitos y es bueno entonces la
gente encerró no se encerró allá también
muchas veces si lópez obrador
este es un jefe de estado que
evidentemente no va a hablar de lo malo
de su gobierno ni en un informe pero
pero a veces también querer encontrar un
granito en el arroz diciendo a ver si
están analizando a veces la gente no no
no se guarda como debe como debería y
esto es culpa del gobierno y luego
diciendo es que la gente guardo de más y
por eso bajaron los delitos pues bueno
son una cosa y otra los aumentos al
salario mínimo es real es real que el
opresor tiene tiene diálogo tiene buen
diálogo hay mucho respecto de la clase
empresarial a lópez obrador y hable de
los impuestos pero
pero si es cierto lo de los que han
comprado la idea del progreso con
justicia es cierto se aumentó el salario
mínimo y los empresarios por medio de el
consejo coordinador empresarial que
ayudó a la negociación
si apoyaron la iniciativa de que las
empresas tenían que dar más a los
retiros de la gente no que la gente
aportara sino que las empresas tenían
que meterle un poco más a que a que el
retiro sea un poco más digno
y aún así sigue sin serlo entonces creo
que si han cambiado cosas se han
cambiado cosas para bien
'los el progreso con justicia es una
frase que me gusta porque real y es tan
real que la gente votó por eso el tema
de la seguridad lo ha venido diciendo lo
que sólo yo lo escuchado 18 años es
decir que la seguridad empieza por
trabajo educación y bienestar
es real también lo que dice de las de la
separación de poderes que el fiscal no
fue que él la suprema corte el
presidente de la suprema corte tampoco
fue y dice una frase que me gusta mucho
que ya he escuchado hablar el hablar es
también la frase que dice los invite y
no vinieron tiene la arrogancia de
sentirse libres es verdad
los invito a usted con entonces esto
habría sido imaginable en otro momento
claro que no
entonces creo que es si hay cosas y hay
logros si es un cambio es un cambio de
tan de fondo tan de raíz que si va a
traer
grandes resistencias y sobre todo
incomprensiones no pero creo que que es
mínimo
hay que darle que lópez obrador todo lo
que nos dijo en campaña todo lo que nos
dijo que él es y ahí está yo sí pongo el
granito en el arroz osa mi granito no el
arroz si lo pongo en el tema
y ecología
un poco la renuncia del secretario
ecología yo no yo sigo sin comprar la
idea de que lópez obrador no apoyar las
energías limpias
es cierto lópez obrador no apoya la
manera en que se hacen los contratos a
las empresas extranjeras que vienen a
vender las energías limpias es diferente
y lópez obrador sabe que somos un país
petrolero y que este bono petrolero que
se va a acabar
más pronto que tarde o sea si nos dura
diez años nos tenemos que dar por bien
ser servidos que tenemos que
aprovecharlo ahora entonces sí sí
tenemos que apostarle a un rescate a
pemex pues ahorita si en unos años nos
ha es ahora o nunca si tenemos que yo si
yo se apoyaría el fracking por ejemplo
que el ofs obrador ahí como que tiene un
dogma muy de izquierda que se llama
fracking pero pero creo que yo creo que
hay que entender un poquito de dónde
viene la resistencia de lópez obrador a
estas cosas que dicen no es no es
precisamente energías limpias no las
entiendo no me gustan ya mí me encanta
el petróleo no o sea es energías limpias
pues ahora no creo que es el momento y
sobre todo sino como lo indicó planteado
gobiernos han anterior esto si federico
te interrumpo entonces en ese momento
para ir un momento con nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico y ahora
en un poco lo que estábamos hablando
antes de comenzar a este discurso del
presidente lópez obrador y es que esto
se da entonces
de cara a estas elecciones de medio
término del año 2021 y mário quedamos
entonces la importancia de estas
elecciones porque son tan importantes y
algunos además la catalogan como
histórica
así es son el propio instituto nacional
electoral ha dicho que es la elección
más grande de la historia de las más
grandes que han organizado y hay un hay
un detalle importante el propio
presidente ha dicho que bueno su
intención es que se acaben los paraguas
que él mismo va a denunciar a cualquier
servidor público que esté tratando de
incidir en las elecciones que no va a
permitir que se utilicen los cargos
públicos para promover algún partido
político y lo cierto es que pues hay
algunas encuestas en donde si buena
parte de los estados que cambiarán la
gubernatura simpatizan con morena
partido del presidente sigue siendo
fuerte por lo menos en algunas
proyecciones electorales en rumbo a
estas elecciones intermedias y pues
estará también en prueba la capacidad
realmente de que se cumpla esta palabra
de no permitir que funcionarios de su
gobierno intervengan hay un elemento
importante
y es que el coordinador de los programas
de bienestar gabriel garcía hernández
pues fue quien organizó el padrón
electoral de morena en este sentido
bueno ha habido mucha suspicacia en el
sentido de el vínculo que puede haber
con la entrega de apoyos y realmente las
preferencias electorales o incidir en
estas preferencias han circulado algunos
audios por ejemplo de representantes del
gobierno federal en algunos estados
precisamente para la entrega de apoyos
en donde pues se se busca de alguna
manera influir en los beneficiarios de
estos programas para la decisión de
quién es el que está apoyando qué
partido está apoyando esta entrega de
apoyos veremos por supuesto que falta
aún por verse cómo será el actuar del
gobierno pero esa es la promesa esa es
la promesa del presidente de que por
primera vez no habrá fraude por lo menos
organizado desde poderes es su
convicción su oferta
y es un proceso electoral ciertamente
complejo que se da en medio de este
contexto de crisis económica de crisis
sanitaria y que pues es el juego y el
actuar de la autoridad electoral también
será fundamental así es mario también
habló sobre la corrupción y antes de
entrar en ese tema con nuestros
analistas vamos a escuchar entonces lo
que fueron algunas de las aclaraciones
de lópez obrador sobre la corrupción
desde francisco y madero nunca un
presidente había sido tan atacado como
ahora
los conservadores están enojados
porque ya no hay corrupción y perdieron
privilegios
sin embargo gozan de una absoluta
libertad de expresión y ello es prueba
de que hoy se garantizan las libertades
y el derecho a disentir la represión
política ha quedado en el pasado
raymundo y quiero ir nuevamente con
usted porque uno de los ejes de su
proyecto político del presidente obrador
ha sido la lucha contra la corrupción
pero también se ha registrado varios
escándalos donde incluso colaboradores
cercanos y también su hermano se han
visto señalados por presuntos actos de
corrupción como esto afecta o no
políticamente al presidente
bueno si podemos ver que hay una
afectación política y si nosotros vemos
por ejemplo las la encuesta publicada
este mismo viaje en el financiero donde
se ve que en un mes una caída de
aproximadamente unos 8 puntos no lo
tengo exactamente muy bien pues son 68
puntos con respecto a la percepción que
tiene la gente sobre la universidad del
presidente es decir si vemos que tuvo un
impacto qué tan profundo puede ser el
impacto todavía no lo sabemos esto
tendría que ser tendría que ser
continuado de cualquier manera en la
profesión del presidente sigue estando
en un nivel muy sólido muy robusto y un
promedio del 5%
dicen bueno ha caído un 20 por ciento ha
caído el presidente porque estaba muy
muy alto 58 por ciento es muy buena pero
si esta parte del atributo sobre la
honestidad estamos viendo que tiene una
bien una repercusión directa sobre
en lo que piensa la gente de él ahora el
tema del combate la corrupción el
presidente
tiene muchos años hablando sobre la
corrupción no ha cambiado ya que es la
parte para mí toral no ha cambiado en el
énfasis de combatir a la corrupción
mediante combatir a la un pie a la
impunidad la corrupción es un fenómeno
que ha existido en este país y va a
seguir existiendo como existe en todo el
mundo la manera como se combate a la
corrupción no es pensando en que se
puede erradicar porque no se ve radicar
eso está totalmente comprobado lo que sí
se hace es inhibir a la corrupción
mediante el castigo a la impunidad
entonces entre más se eleve el costo de
tener que pagar un costo penal augurado
nada penal o administrativo entonces más
de menos gente va a estar inclinada a ir
a cometer un acto de corrupción o lo va
a pensar dos veces no lo va a impedir
insisto pero si de inhibir la corrupción
eficiente no está en la lógica de la
impunidad el discurso del presidente con
respecto a la corrupción es un discurso
de político y cuando digo dominantemente
político es que le sirve al presidente
para para poder mantener muy bien
aceptada su narrativa en contra de todo
lo que significa el pasado el único
presidente en su informe él dice que
para el primero de diciembre de este año
el best art
van a estar todos los cimientos de lo
que es la transformación del país
es decir para el estos dos primeros años
de gobierno que se cumplen el 1º de
diciembre el último día de de noviembre
es lo que él necesita para lo que ha
dicho para que lo que haga sea imposible
de que se pueda revertir me gustó mucho
por la sugerencia cuando habla de la
revolución de las conciencias de la
revolución de la conciencia de las
conciencias en esto en una reflexión
inmediata rápida en tiempo real y me
parece que tiene muchísimo con el tema
de la corrupción si mete el tema de la
corrupción y logré injertarlo de manera
que muy sólida permanente en algunos
casos en la mente de las personas lo que
él está buscando es que estas unas
personas como lo dijo hace unos minutos
sean las que defiendan su proyecto
porque el proyecto lo está llevando a un
nivel ético tomiko entre
para poder llegar a esto tenemos tenemos
que erradicar la corrupción pero está
erradicando la corrupción no está
erradicando la corrupción está creando
esta semilla en la conciencia de los
mexicanos porque digo que nuestra que no
está luchando realmente para reducir o
eliminar al máximo posible la corrupción
porque no hay un tema de impunidad
cuando no hay un tema de lucha para que
tratar de acabar con la impunidad que es
realmente el cáncer que tiene este país
y otras sociedades pero este país lo
demuestra él mismo cuando en sus propias
comparecencias matutinas de estas
famosas mañana era su método de
comunicación política y de gobierno
constantemente él está violentando el
debido proceso y lastimando el estado de
derecho al
adelantar investigaciones que por la
misma razón de la investigación
requieren ser requieren secrecía al
acusar de corruptos a personas sobre las
cuales no hay todavía ningún juicio
tenemos un caso ahora en el informe
mencionó a genaro garcía luna que está
bajo proceso por presuntos actos de
corrupción con el cártel de zerolo y de
eeuu no hay una investigación aquí y el
roda como allá como culpable es decir el
mismo presidente altera por completo lo
que es el debido proceso si este país
fuera de leyes todos estos casos
terminarían cayéndose porque no hubo la
equidad y la presunción de inocencia
entonces pero no es lo que le importa
presidente le importa el manejo político
de la corrupción y raimundo ahora vamos
a tocar entonces otro tema que es el el
tratado entre méxico y canadá para ir
también le quiero preguntar a nuestro
sea nuestro ubicada a nuestra mitad o
federico pero antes vamos a escuchar
entonces lo que dijo el presidente
obrador sobre ese tratado
en estos momentos de crisis el acuerdo
que firmamos significa impulsar las
actividades productivas conseguir más
inversión extranjera crear más empleos y
lograr más bienestar para nuestro pueblo
en este contexto debe verse mi visita a
washington para entrevistarme con el
presidente de donald trump quien nos
trató con respeto y lo más importante
elogió a nuestros paisanos que viven y
trabajan honradamente en eeuu de américa
federico quiero ir nuevamente con usted
y preguntarle entonces la relación con
eeuu y méxico porque ha sido muy
criticado
en la visita que hizo el presidente
obrador a washington y como ve entonces
la relación a trump obrador o méxico
eeuu y ya nos quedan aproximadamente 6
minutos del programa les pido que sean
lo más breve posible para tratar de
meter todos los temas que más nos quepan
en este especial de noticias adelante
federico
primero y muy rápidamente el tratado se
negoció con el gobierno saliente de
enrique peña nieto con alguna asesoría
del gobierno de lópez obrador y fue muy
celebrado en el momento que fue aquí no
recuerdo que alguien haya dicho que
quedó muy mal lo celebró el gobierno de
enrique peña nieto lo celebró el
gobierno de lópez obrador y en general
creo que en eeuu es lo celebraron que
creo que un buen dato
tratado que sin mejorar las condiciones
laborales de sobre todo de las personas
que trabajan en la maquila en méxico
porque el tratado está muy centrado a
que el tema laboral tenía que mejorar si
si queríamos exportar hacia eeuu eeuu lo
hizo con algunas ganas de que armadoras
sobre todo de coches dijeran no nos
conviene méxico en este sentido porque
ya no se convierte en una mano de obra
tan barata pues nos vamos para allá pero
sobre todo las armadoras japonesas han
mejorado sus condiciones de trabajadores
enormemente sin irse del del país
entonces creo que el tratado hasta ahora
ha sido muy positivo la visita así como
que muy criticada digo probablemente de
fuera de méxico pero pero también se vio
como una cosa y raymundo o no me dejará
mentir o sea todo el mundo lo dijo lo
dijimos hoy en el balance a lópez
obrador de la visita que hizo a eeuu y
se vio con rompe en la casa blanca fue
positivo el discurso del observador fue
muy bueno
creo que trump no tuvo ningún arrebato
antimexicano en ese momento luego está
en campaña también está en campaña y es
el spot que criticamos todos al decir
está usando al presidente mexicano
trump en sus spots de campaña el spot el
que yo he visto mínimo lópez obrador
sale menos de dos segundos o sea y es un
spot de dos minutos entonces
no creo que haya sido una mala visita
creo que fortalece mucho nuestra
relación con eeuu y creo que lo debemos
dejar hasta ahí porque tampoco me gusta
que méxico se meta mucho al tema
electoral y creo que el trump lo va a
dejar ahí en ese spot no creo que prom
va a seguir siendo trump y va a seguir
después picando contra los mexicanos y
va a seguir haciendo su campaña para
agradarle a su el electorado sí pero
pero no creo que afecte no creo que nada
creo que el tratado fue muy positivo y
creo que la visita también ahora quiero
ir con raimundo raimundo le pido que sea
muy breve y valemos el avance de los
programas sociales del presidente
obrador que también son un fuerte en su
en su lema de gobierno
sí por supuesto el paciente reforzador
tiene lo es muy intenso en los problemas
sociales
aquí no hay lo que ha hecho el presente
el abusador es una transferencia directa
de recursos y le ha puesto un piso a una
evaporación adicional a los más pobres
en los menos desaventajados quizás la
única crítica que habría a los programas
sociales recientes procesadores que no
hay una verificación en doctor me dio un
seguimiento pero de que han sido
eficaces como él mismo lo señala de que
han sido importantes particularmente en
estos momentos de la de todo lo que
generó la pandemia de la comey 19 creo
que es un punto muy muy a su favor y ya
veremos como por eso tiene este problema
de dinero porque no hay no son programas
sociales que como en el pasado tenían
una parte d
de trabajo con un trabajo en donde el
gobierno aportaba sumas pero también
tenía que generar temas de productividad
de estos planes sociales es
transferencia directa donde no tiene
donde generar productividad me genera
auto tipo de crecimiento en el empleo de
manera de pri manera formal pero no se
le puede quitar en absoluto este tema al
presidente de la república eso sí muy
muy consistente sobre todo de libre
comercio si lo negoció el gobierno de
enrique peña nieto pero después es la
parte criticable hubo algunos ajustes ya
en este gobierno particularmente en el
tema laboral que eran las demandas de
los de nunca atrás en eeuu para que se
aprobara entonces hubo varias demandas
sobre el tema de la de inspectores
laborales de eeuu
llamados agregados laborales para
vigilar contratos colectivos de empresas
en territorio mexicano así como en
patente industrial pero el 20 grupo te
interrumpo raymundo y rápidamente
federico quisiera saber su opinión sobre
los programas sociales del presidente
obrador muy rápidamente tenemos 30
segundos aproximadamente
los jurados sociales del presidente
funcionan y creo que
cuál es la manera la mejor manera de
verificar de auditar los como dice
raymundo tiene razón no no no no hay una
auditoría muy precisa sobre en realidad
si cesc si el dinero está llegando a la
gente o no pero creo que si hay y se
llama aprobación del presidente y la
aprobación del presidente si bien ha
caído temas pandemias o no yo no creo
que haya caído se alto y podemos tener
un programa entero sobre encuestas
entonces brevemente digo la aprobación
de lópez obrador erigen las presidentes
con mayor aprobación en el mundo sí sí
lo es
esperamos entonces tener un poco más de
tiempo una próxima oportunidad para
seguir analizando este complejo panorama
en méxico raymundo federico muchísimas
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros y por supuesto hasta a nuestro
corresponsal en la ciudad de méxico
mario carbonell hasta aquí este especial
de noticias continúe con nosotros porque
hay mucha más información hay empresas
24 en día
[Música]